suit un prof de danse propres de denrées
et produits de la de zumba oui voulait
pas nous faire un petit truc de zumba
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on est quelqu'un qui s'est lancée un
look ou benoît densité rare oui à benoît
l'état peut donc garder dans mon dos qui
me rassure pas aujourd'hui je suis votre
troisième bekri benjamin rester calme
quand même sur une jambe ce concours
sens bien mathieu j'adore c'est pas de
la somme à notre musique pendant mathieu
ne me cachais pas trop quand même
quitte à q1
[Applaudissements]
ouais
ah ouais
[Applaudissements]
non c'est bien oui ah oui merci
alors contrairement contrairement à
osaka grenoble était ou non
belle entrée en matière reste élevé le
zumba non non c'est bien contrairement
aux apparences vous êtes en situation
d'handicap il faut qu'elle nous
expliquer parce que comme ça oui voilà
c'est pas évident je m'assois et je
reprends un peu d'inspiration a déjà
fatigué l'émotion c'est bah oui c'est à
cause de batailles de benoist non trop
de virilité tulle et virilité et dino
[Rires]
vous en savez quelque chose alors oui
aurais je vous écoute en fait ça le
cancer dans notre famille se transmet de
génération en génération
donc je suis aussi réducteur c'est
héréditaire et je suis ici pour pour
défendre une association qui s'appelle
génétique cancer parce que fondée par ma
soeur laetitia mendes je suis donc
touché par une mutation génétique qui
s'appelle brca2 donc j'ai perdu ma maman
d'un cancer du sein en 2006 et donc j'ai
décidé de me faire dépister pour savoir
si le risque de développer un cancer il
faut savoir que les concerts génétique
enfin les cancers peuvent être génétique
ou d'origine héréditaire donc voilà j'ai
beaucoup d'émotion quand je parle de ça
c'est voilà comment zilina j'ai dit et
vous avez commencé en fait opération
j'ai devancé la maladie y avait 70% de
chances de développer un cancer du sein
doris et de risques voilà de risque et
de ouais ouais c'est ça merci mathieu et
faut toujours compter sur lui du coup
voilà j'ai décidé
j'ai décidé donc de subir une ablation
totale des 200 en fait voilà pour ba
pourrait pour éviter de contracter la
maladie
voilà donc c'est un toujours un sujet un
petit peu chez lui en parler voilà on
case est bienvenue et merci d'être là
[Applaudissements]